foreign
fighters let's dive in boxing star
Canelo Alvarez commented on Kamara
usman's loss to Leon Edwards at UFC 279
Canelo who has been called out by Usman
in the past had nothing but kind words
for Usman despite their history
and lastly Canelo you know Camara Usman
he called you out uh now he gets he gets
knocked out in his title fight
you know this this Captain is done by
the sport so
everybody can lose you never know I
think he was winning right all the five
just one one single punch change
everything look he's a great fighter
Dana White reacted to news of the
rumored Jake Paul Anderson Silva boxing
bow at the post fight press conference
for Dana White's Contender series white
said it would finally be a real
challenge for Paul but shot down
attempts at follow-up questions from
reporters video courtesy of the Mac life
there's a rumor that Jake Paul and
Anderson Silva are gonna fight in
October
um what are your thoughts on that
I I don't give a [ __ ] you know what I
mean but if he's really fighting
Anderson Silva if he's really fighting
Anderson Silva if that's true
it's about time yeah he's got a real
fight in his hands there you know
regardless of how old Anderson is
um
yeah going back to Jake Paul and
Anderson Silva would you be tempted come
on are you serious no I'm not tempted to
do anything would you be stop asking me
about Jake Paul you guys I I don't give
a [ __ ] what Jake Paul does Jake I know
you love this [ __ ] and I know it gives
you clicks but come on come on
the guy has nothing to do with my
business I I it's nothing to do with my
business he doesn't fight for me he's
not even in the same [ __ ] sport as me
I I don't want to talk about him anymore
it's I don't care
Sean O'Malley had some words of caution
towards fellow up-and-coming Superstar
Patty pimlet on his podcast the Timbo
sugar show O'Malley said that pinlet's
weight gain between fights isn't healthy
for him it will age you quick I never
really get fat ever but even when I'm
bigger it's like I can't train I mean I
still can and I feel stronger at that
weight but it's not realistic I'm not
going to be 159 in the cage ever I get
in the cage 155 154 whatever so it's
just not good it's not good he probably
never really was making a ton of money
now he's making good money he's
traveling to the United States he's
going to La eating all this all those
opportunities I would love to go eat
with him jail Sonnen had some harsh
words for the former double champ Conor
McGregor on his YouTube channel sonen
said he doesn't believe that McGregor
will ever be a world champion again but
still expects him to put on the biggest
fights for the promotion Conor
McGregor's Championship run is over
that's true that's mean Conor did not
come out and tell you guys because he's
not aware of it I say Conor McGregor's
Championship time is done Conor
McGregor's record setting isn't Conor
McGregor's live gate is not Conor
McGregor's pay-per-view these things are
not done his time in the spotlight and
his time as a main event these are not
done not at all Ben askern has been
retired from MMA since 2019 and retired
from competing in all Combat Sports in
2021 after suffering a knockout boxing
loss to Jake Paul however responding to
a fan on Twitter askren said there is a
fight that would get him out of
retirement a rematch with Jorge masvedo
mozvidol famously knocked out askern in
five seconds with a flying knee at UFC
239 when asked by a fan how the rematch
would go funky Ben Astron responded it's
the only thing that I would come out of
retirement for the headlining event for
October 15th's Fight Night Sean
Strickland vs Jared cannonier has been
canceled Sean Strickland required
surgery after developing an infection on
his finger due to punching a sparring
partner in the tooth Strickland posted a
video to Instagram describing the
unusual situation
okay I was going really [ __ ] good at
a hard spawning Thursday
I woke up Friday and I was like hey you
know my fingers are sore and then
throughout the day I was like my fingers
[ __ ] so I went to the hospital turns
out I have a really bad infection from a
tooth
and uh yeah they're gonna cut me open
drain it out and [ __ ] man I should have
went to college guys I don't [ __ ]
know I'll be out for like three weeks
though so
in life right Headliners for this
weekend's UFC Fight Night Paris surreal
gone and tied to evasa were photographed
in front of the Eiffel Tower for
promotion of the event the pair appeared
to be cordial and had some fun at the
shoot by doing tuivasa's signature Shoei
pose gone is currently a minus 550
favorite to win the fight with tuivasa
tabbed as a plus 400 underdog
[Laughter]
perfect
beautiful guys okay
anything else that's it that's it
yeah like this
no it's more like this yeah
[Laughter]
this is for after the fight yeah
UFC Paris this weekend will be a special
night for surreal gone as he is a
headline fighter in his home country on
episode 284 of the weighing in podcast
with Josh Thompson and Big John McCarthy
Thompson broke down the meaning of
fighting in front of your own people as
well as the pressure that comes with it
look when Bellator went there they sold
out and they sold out quickly I can
imagine this thing sold out extremely
fast and then on top of that it's
probably standing room only in the
hallways I mean I'm just being honest
this is a big big deal and to think that
he's not going to be feeling some sort
of pressure you think fighting for the
title was a lot of pressure try fighting
with your family your friends your
friends you haven't talked to in five
six eight ten years now we're all coming
to watch you hitting you up through
social media hitting you up through your
phone calls your text messages
everything they're coming out of the
woodwork and they can be a distraction
so I hope this last week and this week
that he's in right now that he's just
got his phone's turned off or he's got a
burr phone for his loved ones only the
ones that he truly that's really what it
came down to after my first fight
I fought in San Jose after that first
fight I went and got a burger phone and
I just I used the burner phone the week
of the fight and turned my own phone off
and just only I only had certain people
have that number it was only about three
or four people to have that number if
you want to get a hold of me you had to
be able to get a hold of them if you
didn't have their number you couldn't
get a hold of me this is how it worked
and so it was best for me and then uh it
worked out perfectly so this I'm hoping
for him that he takes this experience
and absorbs it all but not the negative
side which is everyone coming out of the
woodwork just trying to bother him
asking for the just for such Petty
things you know like I said where's the
after party where's the weigh-ins look
it up man like look it up UFC pound for
pound King Alexander volkanovsky
suffered a shocking loss when he ran
into internet sensation hezboola at a
restaurant
[Music]
oh
what happened there
I forgot that the chili
[Applause]
the Chili's in the eyes now too
[Laughter]
looking for more original MMA content
check out the rest of thick boy YouTube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shop
show food truck Diaries and Fight Night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
foreign